[Music]
what's the deal with airplane
peanuts in the sprinter man
that's a big fish all right he'll be
there fishing
no no no no no no he's there he's got it
this is a bonito
today is monday august 15th and as we
speak mark norman is putting on a
bachelor party clinic complete with big
comedy lineups deep sea fishing strip
clubs and more welcome back to the joke
world comedy update every single monday
bring you the comedy news that you need
to know from your favorite comedians
your favorite podcasts who want each
other shows what news specials are
coming out next week when new specials
came out last week the whole comedy
world summed up for you in one place so
please consider subscribing to joke
world right now turning on the post
notifications and downloading this
episode on spotify to support the
channel this is how you throw a bachelor
party
ten miles out at sea mark's pulling in
bonitas
who must die
them are throwing up pretty aggressively
yeah gringo poppy
one of the main things that makes this
bachelor party so cool in the first
place is yeah tampa would be a great
place for anyone to have a bachelor
party but when you're a big name
comedian like mark norman and your other
friends are going to be going to this
party in the first place are also big
name comedians what they did is just
such a cool idea they had a show on
sunday today's monday yesterday they had
a bunch of shows where they'd fill out
the lineup of mark norman joe list r
shafir and special guests people that
were already going to be at his bachelor
party but they decided to all go on the
same shows together and just pack these
rooms you got a pizza and then you're on
the elevator and then uh somebody always
comes on the elevator to go hey you
bring it up for everybody
now what sucks is that i didn't get to
go and i wanted to go to report this on
the news to you guys uh i first heard
about this happening a few weeks ago i
was in tampa at a local open mic and i
was talking to a comedian about it after
the show and he was telling me that the
word on the street is that's probably
sam morell is a special guest because
they advertise side splitters the club
that this was at advertised this as mark
norman joe list r shafir and a special
guest
a lot of people thought it was sam
because obviously they have we might be
drunk that podcast together new york guy
all these guys seem to be good friends
at least from what we can see on the
internet and the other thing was they
they theorized that sam because he had a
show in tampa prior to this event
they didn't want to advertise that
publicly so people wouldn't be like oh
i'll just skip sam's main show i'll see
him when he's in town with mark now for
whatever reason that theory ended up
being wrong the special guest was burped
burnt christler's obviously from tampa
they just did the fully loaded tour
together him and mark a great bachelor
party character i mean if you knew bert
and you were having a bachelor party
you'd be an idiot not to invite him
after all spritz with the boys
joe yeah san diego september 1st 2nd and
3rd you [__] uh don't go to
joe's show instead go to my show in
vegas for big j in september
red rocks sold out i feel like we can
assume that it was pretty electric just
based on the videos that we've seen but
i did everything i could to get in there
i tried emailing the club for some media
access passes because as silly as it
sounds i mean this is the comedy news
they responded and said they didn't want
to take away from the door deal
for these comedians but if anything
opened up they would let me know now
nothing ended up opening up i did not
get to see this show but what's
interesting is that they mentioned the
door deal because another thing that i
heard from some local comedians in tampa
and i don't know if this is true but
what they said is apparently the plan
was to do these shows at side splitters
with this massive lineup mark norman joe
list bert ahri and then take the money
they made from that and spend every dime
on mark norman's bachelor party just go
balls to the wall full throttle just
blowing bags in tampa so if you are a
tampa stripper you better go find a pole
because there is some funny ass people
and one real fat guy walking around
looking to spend some money i'll give
you a thousand dollars if you can climb
up that tree and get a coconut
a thousand dollars come on man's age
need the money two thousand
he's in
get some ukrainian women while you're
there
or you can't do it i already can't even
get a foot up oh wait oh [__] he's very
he's got that freaking he's got a monkey
he's longer than you guys
there's always one school that they find
in like san francisco
there's always one school they use as an
example
where the teachers in front of the kids
and she's like this is my labia
and tonight i'm gonna make it a car
and your homework is to name my new car
and you go that is a bit much
that is excessive
tim dillon's coming out with a brand new
comedy special tomorrow titled tim
dillon a real hero august 16th it drops
on netflix and i'm pretty excited about
it i haven't seen a full long tim dillon
hour
i don't think ever i don't know if you
have i feel like most of his his
specials in the past have been a little
bit shorter like the 30 minute chunks he
did something for comedy central that
wasn't as long and this seems to have a
lot of promise behind it according to
netflix tim rants about fast food living
in texas disney adults and the reason
nobody should be called a hero so these
all sound like great topics that would
be covered on the tim dillon show which
brings me to kind of my main point about
this special i feel like tim dillon is
in a category with a few other people
maybe like theo vaughn who their
personalities translate so well in their
comedy in podcasts you know this past
weekend and the tim dillon show to the
most popular comedy podcasts in the
world and two of the most unique ones
the most unique voices out of these two
guys no one could replicate them if they
tried but when it comes to stand-up
specials neither of these two guys have
that many theo had one on netflix
earlier this year tim you see clips from
every once in a while of him on stage
and i think most people agree that they
would rather see them in their podcast
which is strange because they're such
funny unique voices that like i said
cannot be replicated and then when they
go on stage it almost feels like people
miss what they used to do in the podcast
or what they're used to them doing in
their podcast so that's why i'm curious
to see how this is going to go for tim
tomorrow like i said he's one of the
funniest people has one of the best
podcasts in the world but even tim
himself said he didn't necessarily love
this special you still need to put out
specials david tell puts out a special
every eight years and he's one of the
greatest of all time why is brandon shot
putting out two spots i don't even love
the special that i just shot and it's
coming out because here's the deal it's
like it's i wrote the material two years
ago you saw the jokes two years ago at
vinnie brandt's stress factory but my
whole thing is i want to do it live as
much as i can so by the time the special
comes out a lot of it's topical it's
relevant i don't love it i don't i
didn't love the audience
it is what it is but you know i i
whatever people want to do with their
lives they can do the guest list your
mom's house had on greg garcia last week
two bears one cave was bert and andrew
santino instead of tom we might be drunk
had on bill burr they're the big winners
of the podcast world last week that
episode was huge you guys ever watched
the little league world series i love
that [__] i love it how did you see that
fat kid he was my name so and so my
favorite play is this and i hit dingers
[Laughter]
he just like i [__] love this kid you
gotta love a fat kid
with swagger yeah come on i also love a
sloppy baseball player oh there he is
that's the kid ah this kid's adorable hi
my name is alfred dalia at home they
call me big owl and
[Music]
[Laughter]
wrestling federation
wwe it's like the sandlot remember the
redheaded kid in the sandlot stole the
whole movie yeah i just rewatched that
on a plane baseball movies for some
reason are like the best sports oh the
best durham they had a run rookie of the
year angels in the outfield like ten of
them yeah they also because also it it
it kind of toes the line
of like the pamphlet for this country
you know what i mean it's for hey
everybody can [__] make it the daddy
kind of ignores all the [__] ugliness
of it it's just kind of it's sort of the
santa claus version of uh
of like america it's like yeah that does
exist but there's this other [__] here
so
it's very they're very patriotic yes
type of thing uh david tells joke little
little league world series or as i call
it the pedophile super bowl
something like that
i feel like he's still the [__]
greatest
i think he gets a quote in here like
every week there's always a tell line
joe rogan had on nate forgotten the
honeydew with ryan sickler talked to joe
derosa last week whiskey ginger hat on
paul versi kill tony tonight is annie
letterman and we still have not had a
new flagrant episode drop the last one
they did was ksi as far as new specials
go we have tim dillon a real hero coming
out tomorrow then mike cannon is doing
an all crowd work comedy special that's
coming out wednesday august 17th which
is the same day that tim dillon is
joining the your mom's house crew tom
segura christina p and josh potter for
their live event that is coming out
wednesday august 17th as well thank you
for watching this episode of the joke
world comedy update that's it for this
week in comedy come back next monday for
another full episode of comedy news from
your favorite comedians and podcasters
and
you can see me and i'll talk to you and
i'll tell you about comedy stuff that
you could find on your own but it's a
lot easier just watch these videos
thanks again
please subscribe
[Music]
you